yo Yoshi boys easy I'm here with
bleacher report we playing start [ __ ]
cut in that order
let's get it start the moonwalk the
middle one cut that we're gonna pitch
the dougie for a little bit start
tequila [ __ ] and whiskey cutting Bobby
start pizza cutting wings and we fit to
say up several layers here no vegan
Tom Brady's overtime Green Sozo gonna
[ __ ] him got cut Tiger Woods I'm sorry
we got started Serena Williams she's uh
she's a very strong woman
Queenie she's gonna I saw what you did
there
you started all three all three those
are classic albums and the car two three
was one of Wayne's best albums other
than the carter one that spotted one is
my favorite little Wayne town get
Richard out trying is a 15 fence body at
work here you will print I grew up on
that so I already know what that is he's
gonna be hard to break those down that's
a great question
I'm here with bleacher report and I'm
talking about my new sports agency 8099
and all you young athletes know to come
howl at the big homie and they hope to
get right baby we're gonna build them
finances broad net portfolio you don't
get you right
eighty ninety nine that's what we do